>> Will Sentance: 303 mili giây.
>> Will Sentance: [LAUGH] Tôi không biết tại sao tất cả mọi người, sợ hãi dự đoán này.
Đó là điều hiển nhiên, chắc chắn.
Tôi biết hàng đợi hoạt động như thế nào, tôi thậm chí còn đặt một chút dấu phẩy ở giữa, vì vậy
chúng tôi thực sự biết cách hàng đợi hoạt động.
Vòng lặp sự kiện của tôi, nó ở đó, hãy chắc chắn rằng nó ở đó, nó ở đó.
Vòng lặp sự kiện, đó là vòng lặp sẽ thực hiện kiểm tra xem cái này có trống không.
Nó trống không?
Không.
Ngữ cảnh toàn cầu đã chạy xong chưa?
Vì vậy, sự kiện đã diễn ra vô cùng hấp dẫn.
Nhưng nó đã chuyển sang ba phần nghìn giây.
Vòng lặp sự kiện kiểm tra ngăn xếp cuộc gọi,
kiểm tra nó thêm nữa không, mã toàn cầu để chạy, và nó hoạt động, chúng ta có tốt để tiếp tục không?
Chúng tôi tốt để đi, chúng tôi tốt để kiểm tra hàng đợi của chúng tôi.
Tại thời điểm đó, nó sẽ chạy là gì?
Chà, nó phải rõ ràng?
Ai muốn tình nguyện?
Tôi không muốn câu trả lời đúng,
Tôi muốn câu trả lời sau những gì một hàng đợi nói sẽ là câu trả lời ở đây.
>> Khán giả: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Brayden,
làm ơn, cảm ơn bạn.
>> Brayden: Xin chào tàu hỏa?
>> Will Sentance: Tất nhiên vì máy in [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC] bcnf nên
nó ở phía trước, tôi biết cách hoạt động của hàng đợi,
anh ấy sai về cơ bản, tôi có nghĩa là chắc chắn tốt hơn là một số điều nhưng
không phải lúc này [LAUGH] >> Khán giả: [LAUGH]
>> Di chúc: Được rồi,
bạn nghĩ điều gì thực sự chạy Brayden?
>> Brayden: Màn hình.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng.
Nhưng điều đó không có ý nghĩa gì, tôi biết cách hàng đợi hoạt động.
Ai đó có thể có một bước nhảy vọt về trí tuệ đức tin,
thay vào đó điều gì có thể xảy ra ở đây?
Tôi sẽ có xu hướng Kayla về cái này.
>> Kayla: Đó là một hàng đợi khác.
>> Will Sentance: Cô ấy nói đúng.
Tôi nói với bạn, trong tất cả thời gian tôi nói chuyện này, tôi sẽ nói một hoặc
hai lần mà mọi người sẽ có bước nhảy vọt đó.
Với niềm tin vô hình, rất lớn hãy hét lên với Kayla, chính xác là đúng.
Có một hàng đợi bổ sung.
Đừng hiểu sai ý tôi,
không gian rộng lớn ở đây mà tôi để lại có thể là một thứ gì đó của một món quà.
>> Khán giả: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Nhưng điều đó thật tuyệt vời,
cảm ơn bạn đến Kayla.
Chính xác là đúng, trên thực tế có một hàng đợi khác.
Nó được gọi, họ gọi điều này trong đặc tả, hàng đợi tác vụ.
Vì vậy, bạn có thể đoán xem cái kia được gọi là gì.
Nó được gọi là hàng đợi microtask.
Đây rồi, hàng đợi microtask.
Và chúng tôi nghĩ ở đâu khi hiển thị được kích hoạt và
sẵn sàng để chạy, chúng tôi nghĩ rằng màn hình hiển thị?
Kayla nằm trong hàng đợi gọi lại hay hàng đợi microtask?
>> Kayla: Hàng đợi microtask.
>> Will Sentance: Hàng đợi microtask, cô ấy được đưa vào hàng đợi microtask.
Nhân tiện, nó đã được trưng bày,
đối số cao đã sẵn sàng để được chèn vào nó,
dữ liệu cao ở 270 mili giây.
Đây rồi, hãy lấy nó ra khỏi hàng đợi ở đây.
Không không không không không.
Không phải ở đây, cảm ơn Brayden đã chơi cùng.
Không, không phải ở cuối hàng đợi ở đó, và như vậy, ở đâu?
Sau khi vòng lặp sự kiện ở 303 mili giây trôi qua,
chúng tôi rõ ràng về mã toàn cầu đồng bộ.
Kayla, bạn có nghĩ nó hướng đến đâu đầu tiên,
bạn nghĩ nó đứng đầu hàng đợi nào?
>> Kayla: Hàng đợi microtask >> Will Sentance: Hàng đợi microtask
cô ấy đúng chỗ, nó lấy hiển thị nó dequeue nó, lấy mã của nó.
Nó đặt nó trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Với đối số được chèn tự động,
có giá trị cao, nó tự động thêm JavaScript gốc.
Nó tự động chèn JavaScript đối số.
Tôi thích điều đó.
Vì vậy, điều đó rất quan trọng để phân loại vị trí.
Và nó thực thi nó, và vì vậy, với Matt.
Matt, cái gì sẽ hiển thị trong bảng điều khiển của chúng ta, ở 303 mili giây?
>> Matt: Cao. >> Will Sentance: Nó sẽ cao,
Tôi nên hỏi Todd.
Nó sẽ cao, chính xác là 303 mili giây,
chúng tôi nhận được cao trong bảng điều khiển của chúng tôi.
Và cuối cùng, đứa nhỏ tội nghiệp của chúng ta,
hàng đợi microtask hiện đang trống.
Và vòng lặp sự kiện cuối cùng cũng diễn ra.
Đã đến lúc đi xuống hàng đợi gọi lại.
Nó tìm thấy gì ở đâu?
Nhưng người bạn nhỏ của chúng tôi xin chào,
người đã đợi ở đó 304 mili giây.
Tuy nhiên, sau khi xóa hiển thị khỏi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, nó đã chạy xong,
cuối cùng chúng ta đang ở 304 mili giây, có thể
vòng lặp sự kiện để kiểm tra hàng đợi cuối cùng của chúng ta, hàng đợi gọi lại.
Trong 304 mili giây, print hello đã sẵn sàng chạy ở đó.
Đó là giấc mơ, nhưng bây giờ là thời điểm của nó.
Nhìn nó thật đáng tự hào.
Nó nhảy lên, vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Đó là in lời chào trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi ở 304 mili giây.
Do đó Ethan ở tốc độ 304 mili giây, chúng ta thấy gì trong bảng điều khiển của mình sau đó?
Điều gì sẽ ghi nhật ký bảng điều khiển nhưng?
>> Ethan: Xin chào.
>> Will Sentance: Xin chào.
Chính xác.
[SOUND] Wow mọi người, làm tốt lắm.
Chúa ơi, đó là toàn bộ mô hình của một JavaScript đồng bộ đằng sau hậu trường.
Chúng tôi có hai hàng đợi.
Chúng tôi xếp hàng in chào, chúng tôi bật nó ra khỏi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi tại thời điểm đó.
Chúng tôi có hai hàng đợi, bất kỳ hàm nào bị loại bỏ khỏi JavaScript,
hoặc ít nhất một liên kết quay lại nó bị loại khỏi JavaScript,
thông qua các chức năng mặt tiền gọi lại của trường cũ như đặt thời gian chờ.
Các chức năng đó khi công việc nền hoàn thành, đứng thứ hai trong hàng đợi gọi lại.
Bất kỳ hàm nào được gắn vào một đối tượng hứa thông qua phương thức then,
và sau đó tự động được kích hoạt để chạy từ bên trong JavaScript
khi thuộc tính giá trị mà đối tượng hứa hẹn được cập nhật tự động,
là kết quả của công việc nền từ một hàm mặt tiền hai hướng như tìm nạp.
Hàm đó không nằm trong hàng đợi gọi lại.
Nó đang ở trong hàng đợi microtask.
Và khi tất cả mã toàn cầu chạy xong, và
không có gì trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, vòng lặp sự kiện sẽ đi và kiểm tra các hàng đợi.
Nó kiểm tra cái nào trước?
Hàng đợi microtask.
Nó sắp xếp lại hàm, chạy nó và
thì chỉ cuối cùng thì nó mới kiểm tra hàng đợi gọi lại.